what's it like being a boy mom if I'm
living in a girl like
sorority of you know different ages
what's it like because I'm convinced
also that I I wasn't meant to have boys
I was supposed to raise girls and it
made so much sense of my life I thought
oh whoa I was put on this planet to
raise girls and that informed me about
everything I'd ever experienced in my
life as if it was a collection to be the
right kind of mother for these girls and
then the right kind of mother for
yourself as well you mother your inner
child that wasn't mothered the way you
needed to be mothered when you mother
them also I'm I don't blame my mom for
anything I blame myself because I raised
myself too so I'm really working on that
yeah and it's thank you for saying that
okay they were always it's not about
blaming parents because they were always
doing the best that they could but our
perception of them is what is sub
jective as children and it is what it is
so it's not about blaming it's about our
experience as kids how we experienced it
I agree the blame game is is not a
choice I ever end up wanting to make not
my mom not my kids dad not anybody I'm I
take so much responsibility sometimes to
a point that's so intense but I'm like
I'd rather take it than give it yeah to
answer your question about the boys
though it's like um UFC Fight Night
every day they're just
everything's a weapon they're punching
each other all the time they're best
friends but they're constantly boys
fight a lot there's a lot of
testosterone happening and they're still
[Music]
little